foreign
hey guys now you know that this channel
is mostly focused on well everything
that's got to do with men and now one of
the recent things that came up is this
new idea that a man or man cannot be
defined anymore
now I don't believe that because if you
believe that it's like saying a cow is
not a cow anymore or a lion is not a
lion
this is crazy
now if you ask certain people today to
tell you what a man and a woman is to
define the term man and woman for some
reason
they can't answer you I mean
what is going on in this world
in case you have forgotten
let me tell you what a man and a woman
is a woman is an adult female human
being and a man is an adult male human
being
see that wasn't complicated was it a lot
of people these days they say that men
should be less masculine they might not
even understand what masculine means but
that's what they say
in case you don't know what it means let
me tell you the dictionary.com says
masculine or masculinity means
pertaining to or characteristic of a man
or man
alright so
you should be less masculine so
basically what they're saying is a man
should not be a man
what
masculinity is mostly about the roles
attributes and behaviors seen as
appropriate for males in society
it is important to understand what a man
is
the roles they play in society their
attributes
you know okay let me say this there are
good men in the world and there are also
bad men in the world so there are good
masculinity and toxic bad masculinity
that I do not agree with let me explain
this a little bit better
good men want to protect the people in
their lives fight for what is right and
good be bold and courageous we want to
be brave tough to handle hardships we
want to provide security to our family
make sure they have bread on the table
and we want to be reliable strong the
pillar of the family
now this is what it means to be a man a
real man and it's been that way for
centuries
I can't go against that because that is
how God created me to be I am a man
but what I do not agree with
is toxic masculinity it is not good for
men
to hit their wives being abusive
trying to dominate over others with
violence being emotionally illiterate
these types of men are not good for
society most of them are extremely
selfish arrogant and egotistical
now let me be clear this is not what it
means to be a real man
and there are women bad women who are
like this as well
this is not something that should just
be targeted on one sex
if this is what you say and believe then
you are probably sexist
some woman can be extremely arrogant
selfish abusive lying lying even about
rape manipulative dominating emotionally
abusive and the list goes on let's not
stereotype here there are good and bad
women out there in the world the same
goes for men good men and bad men
so should men be less masculine well
toxic masculinity yes
but not the normal good masculinity
let me say this and and hear me out you
were created to be a man and if you have
private parts down there to prove it
then be a man and be a great man
stand for truth fight for good protect
the weak use your power to stand up
against evil and work hard to provide
for your family be bold be tough be
courageous be a man
there are different men out there men
who are a little bit more sensitive men
with different DNA genes that doesn't
mean that you're not a man if God wanted
you to be a woman he would have given
you different parts down there
so be a man go and be a great man and
always remember that life is short so
don't waste yours
I'll see you next video cheers guys